welcome back to CBS mornings that's a
perfect song for this segment the FDA
recently approved the first drug to
treat a leading cause of vision loss
affecting at least one million older
Americans CBS News chief medical
correspondent Dr John lapuka is here to
discuss John this is very exciting news
it certainly is Gail and good morning if
you or someone you know is getting older
you'll want to pay attention the
condition is called macular degeneration
and it affects a person's central vision
you can go from this where there's
clearly a spot forming in the middle of
visual field to this where this
Progressive blurriness involving the
entire field now there could be total
loss of vision and it can happen
starting around age 50. the new drug an
injection called xiphovery doesn't
reverse that loss of vision but it can
slow it down seven years ago Bob Norman
did started having trouble reading Tess
revealed he had the advanced form of
this problem in both eyes he joined the
clinical trial to test the drug on his
right eye we spoke with of him and an
eye doctor who is a retinal specialist
who helped oversee the study
the doctor basically said there's
nothing we can do you're going to go
blind eventually I've had to give up
tennis I've had to give up bowling it's
killed my retirement plans the right eye
yeah it stabilized the point where I can
get down pretty far on that eye chart
so uh you know the left eye has got to
be treated or that's going to go blind
what do you think of this treatment and
how big of a deal is this it's a huge
deal this would be the first available
treatment to slow disease progression
for this area of huge unmet clinical
need it would represent the game changer
a beginning of a new treatment era for
these patients with Geographic atrophy
all right doc so how do you know whether
the blurry vision could become worse
you got blurry vision you go to an eye
doctor I mean that's pure and simple
okay people should be getting eye doctor
uh examinations routinely anyway and
increasingly as you get older certainly
by 60 or 65 you should be going once or
twice a year that's what societies
recommend but they'll do that special
exam you know and dilated exam where the
pupil goes open and you have to wear the
sunglasses afterwards they can really
get a great look at the retina because
it's not something that you're just
going to know intuitively so don't
question the eye doctor is that the
person where you get your prescription
or is it an ophthalmologist big fancy
word yeah this it's an ophthalmologist
and and if you do one of the same so an
optician is the person who you know who
makes you know who may you can look at
your eyes or he or she can look at your
eyes so I go to Warby Parker they do why
exam's there is that the same right well
you know it needs to be a dilated eye
exam I mean lots of different people say
they can do it right what you ultimately
want to get to is a retinal specialist
because this is not something where just
anybody can do it there is special test
you're looking and you say ah there
there's that Geographic atrophy that
advanced form and it affects you know
more than a million Americans explain
John why this is such a big deal and
who's eligible because this has never
happened it's never happened before
people have heard the term macular
degeneration does the wet form and the
dry form this is we're talking about the
dry form the wet form which is about 15
of the people there's a good treatment
for for many many years this dry form
there's been nothing so this is a big
advance in terms of so saying it's a
game changer yeah finally I think you
know and it's we're optimistic right
you're you're slowing the the vision
loss you're not reversing it and I spoke
uh to people a couple of eye doctors are
very excited about it I spoke to Dr
Steven Schwartz who was a retinal
specialist at the jewel Stein Institute
at UCLA and 10 years ago I did a study
uh with him he's using stem cells to try
to not just slow the loss but to
actually reverse the vision loss and
have people regain restore the vision
now this is still an experimental stage
but I think people are looking for not
only with this drug to be able to use it
in people with the advanced form also
maybe over time when I spoke to Dr Ladd
about it she thought well maybe the next
step would be to have people who have
intermediate loss to see if it helps
them and then really just early lawsuit
to see if that helps you want to try to
prevent the loss what's your definition
of older American because mine keeps
changing used to be 50. it's 10 years
older than whatever age I am what is it
really for this in this particular so I
think you know I looked at the curve you
know it starts like even in the 40s the
curve starts going up 50 starts going up
more and then by the time you get to 60
and 70 it's it's really going up so I
think yes when you hit 40 you should get
a baseline exam you hit 50 certainly you
should be getting a few in between there
but I think by 50 you should really be
getting them regularly and I looked it
up last night the societies Say by 60 65
you should be getting it every year or
two don't wait to get the symptoms
because you may not have the symptoms
yeah get the good exam let's remain
optimistic all right thank you so much